on the fret side of things we can't take
our eyes off of the regional crises
which are in still in full flow actually
in the neighboring regions of europe i
think primarily of the sahel but i also
think of the horn of africa and i also
think of syria
it forms in a sense a regional arc
around europe of instability
which europe has to get to grips with it
has started to do so
but it's rather a long-term project
involving of course the security and
defense side of things but also
development issues come into play
diplomacy economic development and so
forth so um really we're sitting in a
sea of instability as it were on our on
our doorstep
and they're the the main threats that
face us of course there are challenges
um one can't really call them threats as
such but there are challenges of course
emanating from
from the east one thinks of the rise of
china which in itself isn't a threat but
of course may cause security challenges
in asia which in turn may have knock-on
effects for europe
so
of course europe's security panorama as
it were or vision has to be global even
if a lot of the threats are on its
doorstep
if you take the case of mali for example
you had a number of crises come together
the first one being of course terrorism
a terrorist threat which we know in
europe does affect us directly one
needn't think further than the madrid
bombings or the london bombings to see
this but on top of that you have a
number of layered issues one can think
of transnational
crime networks of drug smuggling and so
forth which comes through the region
which also in turns impacts impact the
you know europe um
i think on top of that um one must also
think a little bit about the spiller
spillover effects of some of the crises
that we've seen
um it doesn't take a rocket scientist to
see the connection for example between
the crisis which erupted in libya
and then the fallout which occurred
through the smuggling of arms through
the return of people through under
development as such in the region to see
how that then impacted on mali europeans
now have to step up to the plate um
of course the major concern here is the
american um uh shift or pivot to east
asia um this in turn means that um the
traditional security um buffer or or
provisions which the us gave to europe
in through nato and after the second
world war and during the cold war
is is steadily moving away from us and
this in turn means that europe must take
much more security responsibility
for its neighborhood
it's clear that the spending issue is a
real concern
but having said that
we can do a lot more together in europe
there are there's a lot more that some
of the key states from a security and
defense point of view can do to pool
their resources um in terms of their own
budgets but also in terms of joint
capability programs as such and uh at
the moment we're not doing as as much as
we possibly could do and that is that
the tasks that we face or the gravity of
the tasks that we face are not being met
seriously
with political leadership with the types
of capabilities that we need and also
the cooperation between member states it
does occur but it does occur at a really
low level at the moment
there have been over the last five to
six years a 5.5 billion reduction in the
amount of outlays which member state
governments
make on r d investments in the defense
sector which i think is quite a worrying
trend now on the other side one could
argue well yes we'll just let the
americans do all of the r d and simply
buy american products at the end of the
day well that's slightly more difficult
in the european uh political framework
of defence industrial cooperation as we
know
whether the member states can
come together in some form of a deal
again whether it be on a bilateral basis
or even small multilateral pockets of
rnd cooperation is is a question which
remains open
a lot of the focus i think leading up to
the defense council meeting has been on
such new technologies whether it be
drones or whether it be cyber security
which i think are really really
essential to the future technological
competitors competitiveness of europe
but also um to the uh military strength
of europe as well as it were through
such technologies that is maintaining a
comparative advantage over over
potential adversaries um whether or not
drones and cyber security however are
enough in themselves
is a different question
i think the focus has tended to move
away from some of the traditional
military assets
which we perhaps take for granted land
forces aircraft
and naval assets as well now it's true
there's a lot of good work going on on
air to where refuelling and so forth but
um i would like personally from the the
council meeting to see perhaps a lot
more emphasis on some of the traditional
assets which adversaries around the
world or potential adversaries are
developing a lot and they're investing a
lot of money in these traditional assets
i wouldn't expect too many conclusions i
mean that the main one i hope is that we
get some form of political declaration
on you know when you start to talk about
defence industrial cooperation when you
start to talk about military capability
development well the heads of state need
to answer one simple question and that
is what do you need them for
and i would really like personally to
hear a coherent answer to this
in a political declaration perhaps one
has to lower expectations but i do think
that there is some margin for maneuver
for the heads of state to put out a
clear signal
and response to the state of defense in
europe that starts with acknowledging
that there's a problem in the first
place
that would be really nice but second of
all apart from the small pet projects
which will probably be announced such as
the development of drones and so forth
we'd really like to see a kind of
long-term perspective of where the heads
of state
really want to move out of this crisis
of defence in europe
and that's not just the question of
projects that they can do together but
it's also about communicating the
necessity of defense the continued
necessity of defence in a post-cold war
and even post-9 11 world
you